president biden is due to speak with
russian president vladimir putin this
morning the high stakes video call
follows groin concern over russia's
increased military presence on its
border with ukraine last night mr biden
contacted key nato allies to discuss
de-escalating tensions ed o'keefe is at
the white house ed good morning
nate good morning u.s officials stressed
they have no evidence that russian
president putin is actually preparing
for a military invasion but they say the
president is going to raise concerns
about military buildup there between the
border of russia and ukraine there are
several subjects of conversation for
this call not only the threat of a
military invasion but also concerns
about cyber security and construction of
a key gas pipeline from russia into
europe as for potential military action
u.s officials say the president will
tell putin quote there will be real
costs and that diplomacy can resolve the
dispute the u.s is threatening potential
sanctions but officials didn't offer
specifics nor did they make any
commitments to send american troops but
instead promised military support for
ukraine if necessary
ahead of the call putin's spokesman said
the russian leader will once again
insist that ukraine not become a member
of nato and demand guarantees that the
alliance will not expand further east
into former soviet territory senior
administration officials say president
biden believes every country should make
its own security decisions putin's
spokesman described russia's
relationship with the u.s as quote in a
very dire situation
all right we'll be watching and as
always thank you my friend appreciate it